it is seven o'clock which means you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster boris johnson
could find that some of his own back
benchers
might be unwilling to raise a glass to
extending coronavirus laws
expect some heated debate but no bar
room brawls when it's voted on
in the comments later today that's the
first steps to a better start in life
for babies and children in england
plenty to talk about
with the children's minister vicky ford
in just a few minutes time
but also this morning face i'm sure many
of you will recognize the former love
island stars adam mcdermott
will be talking to us about her
experience with revenge upon
his new research shows that victims have
doubled
in the last two years she's on the show
at quarter tonight
[Music]
from twisting my melon man to saddling
up the happy monday star bez
will be telling us about the launch of
his own racing club
despite by his own admission knowing
absolutely nothing about foxy
that's at quarter to 10 on this thursday
the 25th of march
at loggerheads over lockdown boris
johnson faces a possible back
bench rebellion as mp's votes on
extending coronavirus legislation
raising the bar bitter criticism over a
suggestion that vaccine certificates
might be needed
to have a pint of the pub
injecting some clarity eu leaders will
hold talks to find ways to boost
vaccine supplies as the third covert
wave sweeps across the continent
they deserve more than just applause
nicolas sturgeon says
all nhs staff in scotland will receive a
pay rise
of at least four percent
through the storm i scan you special
report inside the wards during the
heights of the coveted second wave
a beacon of hope the olympic torch
begins its four-month relay to tokyo
ahead of this summer's delayed games
and it stays unsettled for the rest of
the week with wet and windy weather at
times
and some wintry outbreaks expected
tomorrow where we have a brief cold
spell i'll have the details for you
later
morning all boris johnson could face a
possible backbench rebellion today with
the commons set to vote
on the renewal of emergency powers
granted by the coronavirus act
even though labour is supporting the
government dozens of tory mps
are threatening to rebel arguing that
there's no need to extend their
legislation
the pm for his part is facing increasing
criticism over his suggestion
that pub landlords may be given the
powers to bar anyone
who hasn't had a covert jack our chief
political correspondent john craig has
our first report
in bristol a city that's seen violent
protests this week
lockdown means going to the park is
about the only option for people who
want to get
out and today mps are voting
on extending the emergency corona virus
legislation
for six months and current lockdown
restrictions
into july here some accept the need for
lockdown measures
but others say they should end now that
more people are being vaccinated
personally i'd like to see them keep the
powers but use them more
flexibly because we don't know that this
is the end of the pandemic
i think any kind of unlimited power is
quite a scary thing
and i think it should always be a
temporary measure i think something that
was brought in for an emergency measure
should never just become the norm most
of the populations got their vaccine now
that's what they said that they needed
to do for everything to be open
so why are we still why are we still in
lockdown today's commons votes come
after boris johnson told
mps that when lockdown measures are
eased
drinkers may need a covid vaccine to go
to the pub
i do think that the basic concept of
vaccine certification uh should not be
totally
alien to us you mentioned surgeons and
and the care sector that's very
different to
the ordinary citizen going into the law
so is did you recognize abjection for
covert vaccine certification i think
that that's the the kind of thing that
um you know it may be up to individual
republicans pub landlords claim the plan
is unworkable
and would cause conflict between bar
staff and customers
we've had to jump through hoops uh
everything we've had to do to be
covered secure more maybe than any other
industry that i know of
and to suddenly plant this on top of us
i think is a is an injustice for us
though labour is backing the government
dozens of conservative mps are
threatening to rebel
claiming the six-month extension of the
emergency legislation
is unnecessary there's a whole bunch of
really quite draconian measures
that were emergency measures that have
been in place during the pandemic
and the government wants to extend them
until october three months past that
june deadline
and i haven't heard a single good reason
for doing so in bristol
some scars of the protests remain
and lockdown measures are set to remain
too
john craig sky news i hope to speak to
the children's minister in just a couple
of moments
but let's bring in joe pike good to see
this morning joe um look we've talked a
little bit already in john's piece and
in the introduction about
a rebellion this afternoon the
government will win the vote but
the the size of the rebellion might be
actually quite substantial yeah and
there are conservative backbenchers who
are
very frustrated they think because of
the role of the vaccine is going so
successfully
do we really need all these restrictions
in place and actually today i suppose is
an opportunity a platform
for them to air their views air their
grievances
put their opposition to the government
as you say i think it's
very likely this legislation will pass
and it will give government
uh powers until uh september even though
they will not necessarily
use them to extend the roadmap beyond
june joe thanks very much
indeed well when eu leaders meet
virtually later
the issue of vaccine rollout will of
course be top of the agenda with cases
rising across europe
and several countries imposing new
lockdowns the european commission has
called
for tougher controls on exports of
covered vaccines
the aim being to stop supplies leaving
the block and heading for countries like
the uk
where the rollout is far more advanced
our europe correspondent michelle
clifford reports
the evidence of why more vaccines are
desperately needed in the eu
is there in every nation in belgium
hospitals struggled under the pressure
of a third wave of covid
the government announcing new
restrictions to try and bring things
under control
in france's capital doctors warn the
next month
will be hell even after a new lockdown
was imposed in some regions
it's against that backdrop that the
european commission is pushing for
tighter controls
on vaccine exports saying there had to
be fairness
reciprocity between nations and citing
an unequal relationship with the uk
some 10 million doses had been exported
from
uk from eu to uk
and zero doses have been exported from
uk to eu
the uk and eu have promised to work
together but could fall out over the
eu's new
focus on looking at other countries
vaccination rates
when considering exports the uk is doing
well
but here on the continent only around 10
percent of the population have received
jabs
spain has resumed the use of the
astrazeneca vaccine
after pausing because of worries over
blood clots astrazeneca's failure to
deliver tens of millions of vaccines to
the eu
infuriated the commission and partly
explains the move to
toughen up export rules but many warn
the eu is playing a dangerous game
because europe relies on imports of
components and ingredients
from all over the world to make its
vaccines
this uk factory for example produces
components for the fires of biontech
factories in the eu
pfizer said the free movement of goods
and supply are critical
a sentiment echoed by boris johnson i
don't think that
blockades of of either vaccines or
of medicines of ingredients for vaccines
are
sensible the eu rejects any notion of
blockades on its part
but will fear any counter reaction as
more countries face a third wave of
covid
and when eu leaders meet virtually today
they will have to weigh up the risks and
benefits
of any tightening of export walls
michelle clifford sky news
brussels let's head back to brussels uh
skies alastair bunker there for us this
morning
uh morning i'll start just explaining
kind of the chronology of events today
what what exactly is going to happen
when and
when wouldn't you actually get an
outcome to all of this
well that last bit of your question uh
i'm not sure
uh in terms of when things all start
though uh
midday your time one o'clock over here
as michelle said towards the end of her
report it will be virtual because of
uh coronavirus and very much at the top
of the list will be the vaccine rollout
and i think the eu commission is
fighting battles on
a number of fronts of course very
publicly there is that row with the uk
as to exports from eu territory to other
countries
and primarily the uk because the uk
rollout is so much more advanced
and because astrazeneca is a british
swedish company as well
but also there is an internal squabble
because a lot of countries don't believe
that putting up any barriers is the
right way forward so it's not a
universally held position
but there are disagreements as well as
to who
within the eu should receive vaccines
first and in greatest numbers the
austrians for example
believe that they are part of the
disadvantaged group
and yet most of europe think actually
austria at least
proportionally has been one of the
better countries to roll out
its vaccine so it's an almighty mess
both internally and externally they need
to get together
and work out exactly what to do and
sorted out pretty quickly
because again as michelle was saying in
her piece time
is really urgent many countries in the
eu
including the one i'm in right now are
going to new lockdowns cases are rising
and the fact is these leaders who are
gathering today have their own
populations pointing the finger at them
saying
what are you doing about it you're not
doing enough
indeed alastair many thanks
still to come on the show we are still
hoping to speak to the children's
minister
vicky ford in just a few moments plus
now i don't often put my hands in my
pockets but this morning
a little bit different as we will be
discussing this
the new 50 quid notes uh we'll be joined
with the chief cashier at the bank of
england a quarter to eight but you can't
guess who's on the reverse
we'll be hearing from the shadow
business secretary ed miliband and why
he thinks we need an electric vehicle
revolution
just after eight o'clock
[Music]
at 20 past eight we'll be speaking to
one of the conservative backbench mps
critical of the emergency powers granted
by
the coronavirus act
let's take a look at some of the other
stories making the news this morning
and japan says that north korea has
fired two ballistic missiles off the
east coast
and into the sea the japanese prime
minister say it says the launch is
threatened peace and safety in japan and
the region
and that tokyo would closely coordinate
with washington and seoul
about the north's testing activities
north korea's ballistic missiles are
banned under the united nations security
council resolutions
it is a threat to our country and to the
regional security
it is also a violation of the united
nations security council resolution
we will strictly protest and condemn
their actions
i am determined to closely cooperate
with the united states
south korea and other related nations to
protect the lives
and peaceful lives of our people
people over 50 and those at risk are
being urged to book their coveted 19
vaccines quickly before slots dry up
the national medical director for the
nhs stephen pass
says that anyone who qualifies for a job
but hasn't had one yet
should book an appointment in the next
few days
doctors are calling on the government to
tackle social inequality in the uk
as a matter of moral and economic
urgency the british medical
association says that ministers must
prioritize making the universal credit
uplift
permanent and investing in mental health
and child support services
as lockdown restrictions are eased in
the coming months
a group of peers are warning of
substantial barriers still in place for
uk trade with europe post-brexit a large
subcommittee says that small firms have
been
feeling the impact since the start of
the free trade deal with brussels
in january
and i am very pleased to say that we've
managed to secure the children's
minister vicky ford
joining us on the program ms ford good
to see you this morning
a very busy day a very busy day ahead
for you a very busy day ahead for you
i'm afraid
um the early years review just just ex
tell us just a little bit about it
andrea ledson's been working on this
for the government yes so this has been
a really
important and a timely review that's
looking at
those very very first stages in a
child's life
actually from the moment that the
pregnancy starts right through the first
two years
of a child's life and we know that those
early years are the key stages
of a child's development and and that
the years that child spends
before they start school are actually so
important to set them up for life
so andrea ledson and a group of others
have been looking at how we can
improve uh support and services and
actually sign
posting to support services for families
of very
young children yeah the signposting
aspects of all of this i'm sure will be
warmly welcome the idea that there'll be
a one-stop shop where you can find
everything that you need to know
in those early years just tell us a
little bit more about that yes so one of
the recommendations is that in each
local area they should produce their own
start for life um strategy which sets
out for parents and carers
where they can go and find local support
and local services in their area in
their own area
and then one of the things that i've
been doing as children's minister
and we've been doing as government is
also championing the family hub approach
which is where again a family um can go
through a single front door be that a
virtual front door on the internet or
or a real one such as i have in my own
constituency
and find uh signposts into all sorts of
different services
public services but also voluntary
organizations that
are arranging uh different groups and
support for families
and that is not only for the early years
but throughout that child's life as well
i i have to say i have to say minister
there's been a generally positive
response uh from from the social media
that i have seen this morning but but
plenty of people also pointing out
that the necessity for these changes is
a direct consequence
of the conservative government's actions
on on sure start centers
1300 family centers were closed down by
this government in 10 years
and you're now starting to build back up
from that point well actually no over
the past
um decade there's actually been a
remarkable
improvement in the outcomes of really
young children so we do um
what i call a five-year-old test which
is each child as they start reception we
look at whether or not they're at a
good state of readiness for school and
back eight years ago it was only one in
two children who were meeting that level
it's now
three out of four um so it's obviously
up to uh local areas how they uh
bring together those different services
but um the family hub model which
which i have in my constituency um and
uh there is in other areas
it's a very successful way of
signposting uh people to different
resources so we've put
massive investment into early years
education which is partly why
we have much better outcomes for our
young children than we did
um in the past certainly the the this
early year's review in the action
contained and it does
does rest of course on there being money
available and it does feel sometimes at
the moment
that whilst there's lots and lots of
money for certain things there's not
very much money for
for for others this morning we hear that
north of the border the first minister
in scotland
is awarding nhs scotland staff
healthcare professionals
four percent pay rise across the board
down here
nurses are looking at one percent why
are they able to do it and the uk
government is not
so when it comes to early years supports
you know sometimes it's not not just
about the funding but it's actually
being able to find out what is available
in your own local area and where is
there a breastfeeding support class
what is why is the first minister able
to offer nhs staff
four percent whilst the british
government is offering one percent
in terms of of course um the staff
pay for the nhs workers um and of course
i'm married to an nhs doctor myself i
know how hard our nhs workers have been
working towards this pandemic
um we we do want to make sure that even
at this very
challenging time for the whole economy
that there is a pay rise for the nhs
staff that's been
fed in that suggestion has been fed into
the independent review that happens
every year
i understand that it's not your question
is what why are they able to offer four
percent and we're offering one percent
in terms of nurses pay of course we've
been focusing over the past few years on
making sure that those on
lowest pay um do get an increase so for
example
the salary for a new nurse a starting
nurse has gone up by
over 12 in recent years so um
there's a diff there's they have
different um devolved powers in scotland
but obviously
we will be looking and the prime
minister is looking in the health sector
is looking at the situation
in england and and that's where the
strategy has been really focusing on
making sure the support goes to those
on the lowest incomes as well and this
will feed into the independent review
to which the government's made its
recommendations
minister i wonder though you you will of
course be speaking to your
your colleagues in the in the
conservative party day in day out and of
course
there's a key vote this afternoon on the
extension of coronavirus
uh restrictions i understand given your
position as a minister the way that you
will be voting on all of this but
do you understand some of the concerns
that are being expressed by amongst
others mark harper
so i think you know everybody wants to
get out of this lockdown
and back to normality as quickly as
possible but we also want to not have to
go
back into these measures again um and we
want the
way out of lockdown to be irreversible
that's why
we've set up the road map you know we
have
the most amazing vaccine
program of any country of our size
anywhere out which is really helping us
out of this
um the roadmap has set those very clear
measures
in order to get back to normality and i
think that we should be following that i
think that's the way to give people
that certainty we need to look at the
data at each stage as we come
out of the roadmap but we cannot be in a
situation where we had to take a step
too fast and then have to
have to go back again but the the the
concerns are not necessarily just
limited to the timetable of course
although there are
there are grave concerns amongst people
like mark harper have just mentioned but
but also
in terms of some of the measures that
that are being proposed i mean
we heard the prime minister not that
long ago suggesting that you would not
need to be vaccinated to go into a pub
now we discover that he is going to give
landlords publicans
the the opportunity to insist either on
a negative test
or on a vaccination before people can go
into a pub i mean it's a u-turn it's
certainly a u-turn
but i'm just trying to understand the
rationale behind it when we
set up the road map um way back
um in in february to show us the way out
of this lockdown
one of the things that we said in the
road back was that there would be
reviews of of different situations and
there was
always in that roadmap a review of
um of the certifications the
and use of testings and that review
which would look at
how you use vaccines how you use
testings to keep
um settings safe as we go to that widest
re-opening
that is due before the fourth stage of
uh the lockdown so it's always been very
clear that we would be looking at a
review of all the different measures you
could do in order to take
that really widest step um minister i'm
going to let you go off and get yourself
a glass of water
uh get that thank you very much indeed
cheers for joining us this morning
no as we were just discussing in fact
with the minister the scottish
government is offering nhs staff a pay
rise
of at least four percent uh the health
secretary gene freeman
said the move was in recognition of
their service and dedication
during the coronavirus pandemic
uh well let's speak now to sky sardia
choudhary who's
in the newsroom this morning good to see
you sadia um it is an interesting move
and
and contained in the comments from the
first minister around it you know some
fairly
pointed criticism of what's happening in
westminster
yes and actually for her it is a really
good time to be making an announcement
like this isn't it because
pay increases for nhs workers is
considered a very popular subject
especially
after the year that they've had let me
read out to you nicola sturgeon's tweet
that she put out last night in which she
wrote
our nhs staff deserve more than applause
and one percent
is not enough well let's go through some
of the details of that offer
nurses paramedics porters and other
support staff are included in the pay
deal but doctors are among those
who aren't work or anyone working less
than
earning less than twenty five thousand
pounds a year will be offered at least a
four percent pay rise which means a
guaranteed minimum increase
of one thousand pounds the scottish
government says that's likely to amount
to an average increase of twelve hundred
pounds a year for frontline
nurses and for the lowest paid staff
they will be offered a five point
four percent pay increase well the
scottish government says that if this
deal
is accepted then it will be the most
generous nhs
pay uplift in all of the united kingdom
it's going to apply to 154 000
nhs scotland staff and it comes after
that 500 pound one-off payment if you
remember
that they were given as a thank you for
their work during the pandemic it also
is going to be
backdated to december 2020 which gives
them that extra bit of benefit
now there's already talk that this is
going to shame the westminster
government
into following the scottish example
those were the words of one trade union
today and as you've heard
vicious synax 1 pay increase a proposal
for nhs england workers was considered
quite unpopular i think around 72
percent of the british public who were
surveyed
at the time of that announcement said
that that was not enough
but the uk government says that that is
all that is affordable at this difficult
time
zarya thank you now
time for a few other bits of news that
are kicking around this morning at
some interesting stories and this is one
we'll be touching on a little bit later
with one of our guests in fact
the number of victims of revenge
pornography has doubled in the last two
years according to new research
fifteen percent of people surveyed said
they had seen a sexual image
shared without their consent compared to
eight percent
just two years ago
there's a warning uh that adult social
care is being blocked by the
government's inability to come up with a
long-term plan
a report from the national audit office
says the current system of care is
ineffective
and needs improvement it's calling on
the department of health and social care
to work with the government
to make this a reality
it's been claimed that bowel and breast
cancer may be more preventable than
initially thought
a study by the world cancer research
fund says that thousands of cancer cases
could be avoided
each year through diet changes and
exercise
the olympic torch relay has started
kicking off a four-month
countdown to the summer games in tokyo
it began in fukushima
prefecture and we'll see around 10 000
runners take the torch
across japan the first section will not
have spectators to avoid large crowds
and roadside onlookers elsewhere will
have to wear masks
and be socially distanced
let's turn our attention to the weather
this thursday morning nas is at the wall
with the details how we looking as we
head towards the weekend
oh it is looking rather unsettled in
fact tomorrow we've got a brief cold
spell where we're likely to see some
wintry showers across parts of the north
today rain showers are more likely some
of them will be heavy and thundery
though
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so for the rest of this
week we're going to see wet and windy
weather at times still
and a brief cold spell is likely
tomorrow where we are likely to see some
fairly widespread wintry showers across
parts of the north
even down towards some low levels there
until then we are seeing rain showers
this morning across parts of ireland
northern ireland the north west of
scotland some of them perhaps turning
wintry over the high ground of scotland
first thing
and across england and wales it's quite
cloudy with some showers scattered
across central and south western areas
that will be
uh clearing into this afternoon in fact
for wales and parts of the west midlands
and for much of northern england for
most of the day it will be mainly dry
and bright but there will be scattered
showers across southern and eastern
parts of england some central areas
through this afternoon and showers have
become widespread some heavy in sundry
for island northern ireland scotland
european leaders will meet virtually
today to discuss proposals
aimed at tightening vaccine exports to
countries which are
faring better than them in the jab
rollouts it comes amidst weeks of
tension
between the block and the uk a joint
statement says that both sides
are seeking a win-win situation but
boris johnson has warned that a blockade
on vaccines would cause long-term damage
i will join now on the programme by the
french mp
veronique trille le noire who's a member
of the european parliament's
committee on public health also an
oncologist herself
great to have you on the program uh
doctor um
what what is the position of the
european union i understand
that its leadership don't want to use
the phrase export ban
but but ultimately if the vaccines slow
if the vaccines
slow down coming across the channel that
is what it is
it is not export ban because it is a
transparent mechanism to make sure
that the doses produced in europe
reach their adequate destination to
fulfill the
volumes expected from the contracts
we are not in a vaccine world and
i really welcome the joint statement
where the uk and eu want
to join their forces and
we'll probably have to put some kind of
pressure
on the firms especially on astrazeneca
because this firm does not apply the
rules towards
eu it's doing a kind of
unfair distribution of the vaccines
so again we are not trying to block
exportations in a systematic way where
we we intend to verify
that the firm is following its
commitment
in terms of where does the products
uh
apologies for interrupting but if
astrazeneca is not fulfilling its
contractual
obligations if it's not fulfilling the
obligations under the contract that it's
signed with the european union
then surely the thing that the european
union needs to do is take them to court
well as you may be aware of there has
been
a dispute there is a dispute
ongoing so the juridical part of it
is ongoing the eu is
aiming to kind of juridically attack
the firm but the eu
things and i have the feeling that it is
the same
on the prime minister your prime
minister part
the eu feels that negotiations and
discussions
are the way to go between states we do
not have to be at the mercy
of the firms we have to work together
keeping in mind that it is difficult
because because
all governments want to vaccinate their
own populations
you can understand however i'm sure
though given the frustrations that are
felt on the side of the channel
that you are on about the the pace of
vaccination
across the continent of europe you can
understand the frustrations on on this
side of the channel
that it appears from the perspective of
many many people
or in the united kingdom that we're
being punished for doing rather better
than the european union
i understand and i do not think that
nobody in britain is punished i'm very
happy that vaccination is going on well
in your country but i think that will
agree with me that
facing a pandemic if everybody
is not vaccinated no one is
and the uk will be very much
isolated if other countries european
countries
and other countries including low-income
countries
are not protected so our our duty
as a politicians is really to make sure
that the pandemic
is faced at a worldwide level
i have a concern for the
briton citizens they have to receive the
second dose and
your prime minister has to
discuss with the firm and the european
union to make sure
that this will be possible
you have been vaccinating very quickly
in an emergency which i understand but
from a medical and scientific point of
view
we all have to do according to
science based rules and demonstrations
um doctor i'm afraid we do have to leave
it there but we really appreciate your
time in the program this morning uh dr
valente
elenor thank you so much thank you
well let's bring in uh let's stay with
that story and get another european
perspective on it we're joined by the uh
former prime minister of finland
alexander
mr stop great to have you in the program
this morning what what what do you make
of this
this row that is apparently going on at
the moment how much of
of what we are seeing from the ec eu
leadership
is about the the slow pace of what of
the vaccination roll out on the
continent
and how much to do with perceived
failure failures on the part of
astrazeneca
i think probably a lot of the both and
what i always try to do
is to put myself in the shoes of the
current leaders it's quite easy to do
here from florence and academic world
and i think what they're thinking at the
moment is okay
how can we solve the health crisis i
think the big picture is very simple
by the end of june if the figures are
right uh
all of europe or 70 of europe will be
vaccinated
70 of the population in the uk will be
vaccinated
that's absolutely fine and they try to
look at it from a scientific perspective
all kinds of different directions and
they draw the conclusion that listen
procurement was not a problem but
production has been
then they start looking at who is at
fault here and i think they're looking
at astrazeneca
because if you look at the facts in the
uk and i see the numbers
rolling on your screen there you've got
about 54
of the population vaccinated in europe
roughly 17
if astrazeneca had
kept to their promise europe would have
been vaccinated to about
36 at the moment according to the
financial times estimate so
you know they're looking at things from
a different perspective production and
procurement
what do you think then is that is the
likeliest outcome of this virtual summit
taking place today we understand that
from both sides that they want to see
well they're certainly expressing a
desire
to see a positive mutually beneficial
outcome to all of this but someone's
going to have to lose out
yeah well no i don't see this as a
zero-sum game you know
when we're talking about vaccination
when we're talking about a pandemic
we're all in the same boat
around a country of 65 million people
prime minister of a country of 65
million people might see it as a
zero-sum game given that his priority
is to ensure the safety of his citizens
yes but i think that your question was
about what the european union summit
wants so the way in which the prime
ministers are looking at things
is from two perspectives one is internal
and at home
they are of course dealing with a high
pressure situation
with a pandemic with the lockdowns with
easter coming up
and they have to show to their public
that they're doing well the other one is
of course for instance the british case
so that's the export the outside thing
you have to think about it as the eu
being sort of the pharmacy of the world
at the moment
because it is the one that has the
capacity to produce the most
so for instance now the eu
has exported over 40 million doses
over 10 million of those have gone to
the united kingdom
so the european union wants to continue
this time
over discussion with the rest of the
world and not uh be caught up
you know it's not going to be a perfect
solution coming out of a summit but i
think it's going to be good and if i may
i think at the end of the day when the
dust has settled when
when judgment day comes there's three
things that all heads of state
government have to look at
number one what was the death toll it's
a morbid toll but you have to look at it
per capita and otherwise how did the
government succeed in managing
number two how did the vaccine roll out
work out and as i said
i think 70 of europeans will be
vaccinated by the end of june
and number three how do you get the
economy going again
and this is what the heads of state
government are grappling with at the
moment
not an easy task may i add this this is
perhaps the first
major uh point of disagreement i mean
there are plenty of points of
disagreement between the uk and the
european union ongoing at the moment
fishing plenty of others but
in terms of a major fallout in our in
the post-brexit area
era this is this is perhaps the biggest
one what does it say in your mind about
the prospect
for a close relationship between the uk
and european union moving forward
well you know that my heart is with the
united kingdom not
only uh through marriage uh and
otherwise so i do hope that the
relationship will settle down and calm
down
uh having said that you know if i look
at it and sorry for being a little bit
blunt
from a british say johnsonian
perspective i
sort of understand what the government
is trying to do because
with all due respect the united kingdom
has
after all had one of the biggest death
tolls
uh real and per capita in the world so
what the government needs to do now
is to show that it can manage the
aftermath
of the pandemic better and therefore the
vaccine numbers
become a very big issue in the whole
narrative i
however believe that i think we need to
respect
um all of the casualties and and we need
to tone down the discussion and the
debate
we are in this together and i hope that
will iron out a better relationship
between the united
kingdom and the european union in the
future as well tit for tat
simply doesn't work alexander great to
have you on the program this morning
thanks very much for being with us
now you may well have seen our special
reports from inside the icu award at the
royal free
and barnet hospitals during the winter
wave of covert 19.
some of those interviewed didn't survive
others
face a long road to recovery our home
editor jason farrow looks at the
long-term damage the pandemic has done
to the nhs
and investigates whether it can ever
fully recover
the royal free and its sister hospital
barnet have treated around 6
000 covid patients so far during the
pandemic
more than a thousand have died sky news
has documented some
of those life and death battles and the
impact on patients
their families and staff hey dad
i know you can hear us you can see your
eyes opening
for those who've experienced and
survived the worst of this virus
only now are they beginning to process
what they've been through
i went to bed on christmas eve i was
fine as far as i was concerned
i got up the next day my partner said to
his friends that
she won't get up she won't get up she's
coughing and i have no
memory whatsoever the hospital phoned me
up i said well what chance we got that
night or in the morning
don't hold out much hope that's what
they actually said to me
the christmas period was frightening too
for hospital staff
i remember i'd been with my family in
the daytime i came in christmas night
and
it seemed like this tsunami of people
came in christmas night
and it was the first time ever that i've
come into work feeling
like i can't breathe but nurses like
michelle stepped up
500 staff members at the hospital
adapted their roles
to support intensive care specialists
who were stretched
to the limit you know it sounds awful at
times
we were doing our very best but times
you don't even know the name of your
patient by the end
you might be writing it down all day
long and going through everything but
like i say it felt like the care part
went like
and i feel ashamed to say it was like we
were managing bodies we were trying to
keep bodies alive
but hundreds of lives like perry's were
saved
when i woke up i was very very delirious
i was having imagining all sorts of
peculiar things i thought my parents
were still alive
but my mum died in 86. after more than a
month of intensive care
perry was still on a long road to
recovery
when was that september that was
my birthday what are the main issues for
you now
i'm totally immobile it's left me unable
to walk
all my muscles are so weak and even it's
either hard for me to send a text
[Music]
and covid patients require so much help
often for many weeks
that this outbreak has inevitably
impacted other hospital services for
example
since the pandemic across the nhs the
number of people waiting for more than a
year
for a routine operation has risen from
1600
to more than 300 000. we have to work
our way through
the operations that have not been done
that needed to be done
and then after that of course there's
the very real impact of as the scans
start
and the conditions that haven't been
detected really over the past 12 months
they will come to need management as
well if i could magically stop
coronavirus now
how long would it take you to get back
to normal i don't think we'll ever get
back to
to normal i can't see how we're going to
return to
the royal free itu as it was at the end
of 2019
i think that's just that's now history
we often describe our medics as
heroes but behind the mask they're also
human
i think everyone's a bit broken i've
been in nursing for 20 years
this is like another level like
flashbacks through the night or
a sound will trigger something
yeah i'm not very good at the moment
it's been a long time patients are
grateful
12 weeks after going into hospital
perry's home i was very depressed when
you saw me in the hospital but i'm
feeling so much more positive
yeah and you know i'm able to walk on
the zimmer frame
even if the crisis passes kovid has left
the legacy
a long road to recovery for patients and
the nhs jason farrell sky news
yeah some truly remarkable work in fact
by jason uh visiting those hospitals
and his full hour-long documentary is
broadcast on sky
documentaries channel at 9 pm this
evening and at 9 00 pm
tomorrow night here on sky news
the bosses clearly trust me this morning
a new polymer
50 pound note is being unveiled this
morning it features of course
uh her majesty she tends to put her face
on most of these things these days but
on the other side
the scientists the father of modern
computing in fact i would say
alan turing is on the reverse and it's
going to be issued
for the first time on his birthday the
23rd
of june uh pleased to say that the bank
of england's
chief cashier sarah john jones is on the
program
sarah absolutely fantastic this note
that i'm holding in my hand here you
must be
you must be pretty proud of this
we're really proud of this note for so
many reasons
it's one of our most secure bank notes
yet with the move to polymer
it's got great new security features on
it and as you say
it features alan turing who is a
fantastic character
to reflect all his different
achievements um on the back of the
banknote
um i'm i'm really pleased with this with
this note um
before we move on to of asking about
alan turing and indeed the kind of the
design on the road i have to say
of course as chief cashier of the bank
of england the nice thing is is we all
get to see your signature
on on every in every one of these notes
that's that's being released
how does that feel knowing that your
your name will be in circulation
on so many bits of pretty expensive
paper
it's it's such a privilege to be chief
cashier and to sign the nation's
banknotes
i i'm really really proud of it um and
it's you know it's quite daunting when
you choose the signature that's going to
go on on these banknotes
but it's a really important promise that
the bank of england is making and that
i'm signing up to they promise to pay
which is really what gives that piece of
polymer its value and its worth so it's
a it's a real privilege
um and it's a very important thing to do
as well and tell us then said about
about the decision-making process that
led up to
as i say alan turing a a figure who
should have been far great farmer
greatly revered in his own time than
that
than he even is now but why was he he
chosen
as the perfect person to put on the back
of the 50 quick node
well the the character selection process
started way back actually
in 2018 and we asked the public
to think science and nominate scientists
they wanted to go on on the back of the
50-pound note
and we had over 225
000 individual nominations from the
british public absolutely
amazing response lots of them for alan
turing
but actually he was one of 989
individual scientists who were nominated
and we had our banknote character
advisory committee
of which i'm a member but also involves
seven expert
external members to the bank as well um
we had to go through biographies for all
989
scientists to whittle it down to a short
list of 12
which was taken to governor carney who
eventually chose turing
and i mean he's such a great choice um
he is probably best known for his
code-breaking work um at bletchley park
during world war
ii um which has been attributed with
shortening the second world war and
saving millions of lives
um but beyond that he's known as the the
father of computer science
he envisaged the basics of what we've
now come to know as a modern computer
and the impact that's had on rfj live so
his legacy is absolutely enormous
i mean i'm speaking to you over a
computer over a computer now
and that came from turing's original
concept and original idea
absolutely amazing legacy you know what
it said i just i have to admit i was
being a bit cheeky there but the design
of the note is absolutely remarkable
particularly that little bit of
circuit that little bit of circuit board
i think we're going to get the camera in
a second
just in the clear panel we're just about
to run out of time and obviously
security you can't go into specifics but
roughly how many security features do we
have
on this 50 pound note
too many for me to go through lots and
lots of different levels of security
but actually you know there are two very
simple things that everyone can check on
a banknote to see if it's genuine
the first one if you turn it over you
can see there's a hologram
at the bottom that flips when you turn
it yeah if you look at the very bottom
it flips from 50 to pounds when you tilt
it in the light
and if you look at the window just above
that that has that
microchip foil over it again checking
that foil feature and the queen's head
just next to it
looking at those features will really
help you to identify whether you've got
a genuine note
uh well do you know what sarah i've been
told i'm on strict instructions that
this needs to come back to you very very
soon so i'm going to pop it
in my pocket for safekeeping just for
now and say thank you very much for
joining us
sir john great to see you this morning
thank you very much